listen
say it isn't so the third and final
season of this show i can only imagine
the emotions
attached for all of you but tell me
isabella actors dream of being part of a
series like this not just a great series
but a series that is really changing
people's lives and perspectives so now
that we're on the end of it what has
this journey felt like for you
gosh this journey you've been amazing i
i have the words honestly i'm just glad
that i was able to
start off my journey with these people
because everyone's been a family to me
and they will be family
and everything's just been amazing
anthony i know we don't want to spoil
anything no spoilers no spoilers
but what was your reaction when you read
the script the final episode for the
very first time
oh
how do i say this okay okay i'll say it
like i it was very
uh emotional to say the least
um it uh uh i thought it ended perfectly
i think it really encapsulates
everything that we were uh going for for
these uh three seasons so i uh uh yeah
if there was one word to describe it i'm
just saying emotional
and that is a perfect word i think
emotional really really works mateo have
you received messages i'm sure you do
all the time from people all around the
world because this show is so universal
what would have been some of the
messages that you have heard from people
about this series
uh i've seen a lot of people say that
they wish that they had this when they
were like a kid
and
how much the show has changed them and
how
it changed their perspective too and i
just think it's really special that we
have that impact impact on people and
it's it's really great
okay so et canada always loves to get a
little tea here so i need to know
who was a complete mess on the final day
of shooting was there one cast member in
you know that just could not keep it
together because you don't become a
family when you spend time with each
other each of you give me your answer
who was the messiest
um
honestly we all were we were we were all
it was very bittersweet but i i have to
say
i've never seen anthony terpel cry
really ever um so seeing him like just
get so emotional just i think made me
hear up even more um we were all a mess
i don't think there was one person that
was like you know more or less
anthony would you say that uh
what you're hearing is true were you a
bit of a a mess on the final day
cry is a strong word i would say video i
have a video of
you
and they're just stopping stopping
well you know
allegedly i was crying um it was you
know we yeah we were all kind of a mess
it was uh um
uh it was it was
definitely like a
a tough but really fun day
um and
yeah we i think we were all crying uh
michael i'll call michael out too though
since you call michael was definitely a
mess as well
but yeah
i can only imagine mateo what about you
did you see anybody that just could not
keep themselves together on set on that
final day
i think um
i mean everyone is crying hard but i
also remember uh
well listen what i'm gonna come to
one of you for a final little wrap up
here
anthony what do you think that fans of
this series and there are so many fans
of love victor all around the world like
i mentioned before are going to be in
four with the third and final season oh
gosh uh yeah it's you know uh uh the one
thing i mean i really want them to be in
for is uh closure and like a a wrap-up
of these characters that they've been
following uh for like the last three
years um and uh i think we delivered
that and i mean also drama and comedy
and everything in between but really i
think uh
if i want them to experience anything
it's closure
uh isabella is there like a group chat
for love victor between all of you that
will remain that you will all stay
connected with
oh yeah um season one we made a group
chat called love memes because we would
just send memes to each other um so
that's like our primary group chat and
it's it's the best we love it
i love it so much congratulations to all
of you it is pride month so happy pride
and you know what congratulations on
this series it really did change a lot
of lives around the world and you know
growing up i wish as a queer person i
had a show like love victor because it
is impactful and important so thank you
and congratulations again yeah thank you
so much happy pride happy pride
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos